thanks to the organizers both for the
excellent workshop as well as for
inviting me what I'm going to talk about
today is a very simple connection
between optimization problems that occur
in machine learning and a very simple
computational geometry question let's
see what it is but before that let me
set up the problem by asking a far more
general question and so the setting is
high dimensional data so this is a
setting where the number of variables in
my model in my data are extremely large
and so in in the case of linear
regression the signal is extremely large
think of hundreds of thousands
potentially and it's specifically high
in relation to the number of
observations we have so I might have a 1
million dimensional signal and a few
thousand samples so that's the setting
we are in and there are curse of
dimensionality theorems which are
essentially sample complexity theorems
which state that in the absence of any
further assumptions the number of
samples you will need would scale at
most polynomially in the number of
variables that you have and that's if
you have parametric models if you have
non parametric models the sample
complexity is exponential in the number
of variables and so this is extremely
bad because we are in the opposite
setting where we have fewer samples than
variables and so given these curse of
dimensionality theorems we have to make
assumptions we have to impose
constraints on our model even if they
are parametric models and over the last
decade and a half what we have realized
is that essentially we have to impose
low low dimensional subspace constraints
and so these could take the form of
sparsity group sparsity tree sparsity
graph sparsity low rank structure and so
on and so a lot of very nice work has
developed which impose specific low
dimensional subspace constraints and
then show that under these constraints I
can develop very efficient algorithms
that are also sample efficient in the
sense that they can actually learn the
model even under this extremely data
scar
setting and if you think about okay
what's the commonality between all of
these different constraints and notions
of structure if you will so a few years
back we had this notion a very linear
algebraic notion of structure which
essentially amounts to transforming your
signal into a different basis it's
essentially just basis transformation
and so this is very linear algebraic I
think in the first day people are asking
questions about what notions of
structure can we come up with and I
think definitely going beyond linear
algebraic structure is definitely an
important thing to do but what we did
was he said that okay if you have a
linear algebraic notion of structured in
other words you have a basis
transformation and then after the basis
transformation of signal sparse so even
low rank structure and all those
different kinds of things can be caused
in this in this flavor and given that
you can then at this level of
abstraction you can come up with
algorithms you can come up with
statistical analysis that just works at
this higher level of abstraction I don't
need to talk about low rank matrix
structure or groups power structure and
so on I can just work at this more
algebraic abstract level and so that's
something we did and others have done
and so what's up short of all of this
even if I assume this very nice linear
algebraic structure or lower dimensional
subspace constraint upon the model what
I have our models that can be learnt
even in the high dimensional setting
where I have very few samples very large
number of vehicles and so in other words
my advances have been in the statistical
or sample complexity but what about the
computational complexity so if you think
about this high dimensional setting p is
so large that to have efficient sample
complexity I don't want to scale more
than logarithmic lee in the number of
variables but if i want the same thing
for computational complexity that
suddenly seems to quixotic sounds
foolish to ask because if our P
variables my computational complexity
obviously
scale polynomially in the number of
variables there's no way for me to hope
for logarithmic dependence on the
problem dimension but if you think about
increasing problems in the big data
error so in addition of the large number
of samples i also have a large number of
variables make sure if you give me more
samples i can always give you a more
complex model right so i can always
scare my models which are only limited
by imagination and give you such a
complex model that the P is very large
so the question is can we actually do
something by imposing this linear
algebraic structure can you actually
reduce the dependence on on the number
of variables so that's the question you
want to ask and the question is how so
if you think about how we might go about
doing this let's focus on a very simple
structure that of sparsity okay so this
is a setting I want to work with so i
have a optimization problem and so this
are think of this in the context of
learning as learning a statistical model
whether parameters are w and this w is
in a P dimensional Euclidean space so
the number of parameters available zard
up our RP so p is very large and in this
setting I'm going to assume that this
optimization problem that i care about
is has nice properties we can start off
with these nice properties that its
convex and it's smooth so specifically
its gradient Egyptians you can relax
these assumptions but let's just work
with these extremely simple and niceness
properties and what's more I'm going to
assume that the minimum of this
objective is sparse specifically it has
only s nonzero entries so even the P may
be very large so the ambient space is
very huge but the number of nonzero
entries of W star are very small think
of them as constant or scaling log as be
clean p for instance and they're also
bounded I don't want extremely spiky
optic
so this is the setting and under the
setting I want to think of optimization
and doing optimization in a manner that
has more graceful dependence on Pete now
if I think about the usual approaches
they are very skilled polynomially in
the number of variables in the number of
parameters P the best possible thing I
can do is linear but typically it's
cubic and so on so what can I do so why
is there any hope at all of me to
improve something that's polynomial and
P the hope is this last line over here
and even though ambient space is huge
the optima optimum I know lies in the
lower dimensional subspace that's
information that I'm giving you a
priority the question is going to use
that information to 0n on that subspace
if you are able to zero in on these s
nonzero entries then you have reduced at
dimensionality of the problem to X and
then you can just optimize in this lower
dimensional subspace and that's the very
high level intuition possibly q exotic
but at least something we can ask can we
do this and if we want to do something
like this we have to focus on this lower
dimensional subspace constraint and in
this specific case we are focusing on
sparsity so a very natural algorithm to
think about is coordinate descent in
coordinate descent this is the algorithm
it's extremely simple you focus on
optimizing one coordinate at a time so
even though you have P coordinates P
variables or parameters here I'm going
to focus on optimizing one coordinate at
a time so here what we have is cyclic
coordinate descent because what I'm
going to do is given these P coordinates
I'm going to cycle through these P
coordinates one at a time ok so at let's
say this step I'm at coordinate J what
I'm going to do is just solve this one
dimensional optimization problem I'm
just going to find the weight alpha that
along the Jets coordinate that optimizes
that minimizes is
specific loss function that I care about
is extremely myopic focusing on one
coordinate and then given this I update
my weight vector and continue continue
with the second coordinate and so on so
these are actually extremely popular in
large-scale optimization problems
because it reveals a very high
dimensional problem to a one dimensional
optimization problem and one dimensional
optimization problems are something that
we can all do very easily and so this is
cyclic coordinate descent and if you
think about the computational complexity
of cyclic coordinate descent so this is
very popular again because if I think
about it a step-by-step level each step
is actually very simple since I'm
optimizing just one coordinate but the
problem is that even a single sweep
through all the coordinates takes time
linear in the number of parameters and
that's just one sweet typically need
many many sweets the number of sweets
and turn scales polynomial e with the
number of variables and so that's not
good at all right even a single sweet
through all the coordinates takes
nonlinear and so that's really the
caveat but that said given the fact that
each step is simple maybe give me a 1
billion dimensional optimization problem
I took so long as I can quote up this
very nice simple algorithm says that
each step I can run on my laptop I don't
care and so that's why this is actually
extremely popular but we have not
proceeded on answering the question we
raised which is can I vegan the
dependence on the computational
complexity of P by leveraging the lower
dimensional subspace constraint
specifically the sparsity constraint on
the optimum there's no place I've used
the sparsity of the optimum the question
is how do I tweak this guy so that I can
leverage the fact that the optimum is
sparse one way I could do that is to
pick these coordinates intelligently
right so if I had Oracle access to the
optimum or at least at least of the
subspace in which the optimum lies in
other words the coordinates where the
optimum is
10 I could just focus on those
coordinates and perhaps given that we do
not have access to such an Oracle I
might at least do something better in
the sense of an intelligent picking of
the coordinates instead of a just a very
simple cyclic sweep through the
coordinates right so a question is can I
be more intelligent in picking the
coordinates and hope that this
intelligent picking the coordinates will
0m into the truth set of sparse
coordinates so what's something I could
do let's think about the simplest myopic
thing we could possibly do yeah this
thing can be anywhere then you have to
go at least once really border that's
right so so what could you hope to write
so um think of little stuff that's one
thing so there are forward really
algorithms so there are forward greedy
algorithms they just pick one coordinate
at a time and then after picking x
coordinates they could store so let me
go or greedy algorithm that exactly goes
through this procedure which is this so
it picks coordinates in this way so we
sought with some initial estimate but
then instead of cycling through the
coordinates it's going to pick the
coordinates greedily and what's the
greedy step it's going to compute the
gradient and it's going to pick the
coordinate which is the largest
magnitude for the gradient of that
coordinate that's exactly right so this
step is has complexity that's oh of P
but if I think about the number of steps
that this algorithm takes that gets rid
of the dependence on T this is Frank
wolf so this is just greedy coordinate
descent so Frank poof typically we do in
the case of constrained optimization
where our convex how in which this w
lies so here I am looking at
unconstrained optimization so here this
is it and you have exactly come to the
point I wanted raise which is that this
greedy coordinate descent for this very
simple setting has a
these very interesting guarantees which
is that in this case since I'm just
performing this very simple greedy
algorithm in all assuming strong
convexity I have a sub linear
convergence rate so WT the it fits WT
converge to W star at a rate 1 over T
and the constants do not depend on p
anymore they essentially just depends
the l2 norm of the optimum and the l2
norm of the optimum does not depend on p
right if as in that each entry is
bounded why is this just a visit this is
the guarantee of business specialist
this is a greedy coordinate listen so
this is not our result I should have
some this is not our result so I just
wanted to bring up 3d coordinate descent
this is the guarantee of greedy
coordinate isn't and now I want to drink
up the point that you raised which is
that if I can solve the greedy step in
sub linear time sub linear and P then I
essentially have the overall
computational complexity that sub linear
be so that's essentially what we have so
greedy corn and descent the number of
iterations iterations avoid the
dependence on P and the dependence on p
is brought to a sub protein which is
this greedy step and that specifically
takes time that is at least linear in
time but if you think about it it's
actually a very simple approach very
simple problem that you want to solve
which is the the coordinate which has
the highest magnitude of the gradient to
solve this exactly takes time linear and
p the question is what if I'm okay with
an approximate value and I then solve it
in times of linearity and so in general
this is not possible but what I'm going
to do is I'm going to cheat slightly I'm
going to allow you some pre-processing
time so where I'm only giving you access
to the inputs and not the output so let
me now go to a more specific setting
where I will show that this can actually
done in time sub linear in P and the way
I'm going to do that is by
reducing this greedy step to finding in
the nearest neighbor from some residual
vector so have some residual vector at
iteration T and the greedy step just
amounts to finding the nearest neighbor
among my peak columns now this in
general in a brute-force fashion takes
time linear and P but if you have some
data structure and this is where some
pre-processing time comes and if you
have an appropriate data structure in
which you're storing these columns then
you can actually solve this in time
sublinear in p but you can of course the
caveat is that you won't get the exact
nearest neighbor you'll get an
approximate near sleep so that's really
what we are doing and so to see how you
can form this reduction let me go or
something very specific which is a class
of optimization problems as given in the
first line okay so this is a class of
problems which is where the parameter is
w and then two linear combinations with
some inputs X and then have a loss
function that compares this linear
combination w transpose x and some
output Y and you have a whole bunch of n
samples and how to give me the weight
vector W that minimizes this loss
function so almost all in in fact
linearly parameterised machine learning
models can be cost supervised learning
machine learning models can be cast in
this form a linear regression logistic
regression SVM's and so on and so forth
so this is the problem I want to solve
or rather I want to minimize this loss
with respect to the weights W just to
instantiate a particular optimization
problem and how would the greedy step
look like for this class of optimization
problems so for that think about what
the greedy step was it was computing the
gradient of the loss at W and what's the
gradient of the loss it's exactly the JH
coordinate is exactly the dot product
between the JH feature and a particular
residual vector the residual vector just
depends on your current w's and all the
data
ok so this typically you can compute
using cashing in time linear in n ok
this does not have this typically does
not computing this guy with caching does
not depend on p the dependence on peak
comes in solving this problem okay it's
solving this problem to the left so what
you want is given this residual vector
which again compute an O of n I have to
look at all the J features and find the
the feature J set which has a largest or
product with this residual vector right
now if I normalize my columns then this
exactly corresponds to finding the
feature J which is closest in Euclidean
distance to my residual vector ok so
here I use X bar J because i use both
plus minus x of j ok since I'm an
absolute value here ok so that's it so I
just look at the two times P possible
vectors which are just plus minus my
original p columns my p features and
given this residual vector I want to
find the J which is closest to this
residual bit now this takes time linear
and p but if you can store these X's in
an appropriate data structure you can
actually solve this in time sub linear
in p okay but of course if you have a
certain approximation factor and you can
ask ok give them this approximation
factor if i give you if i give you a
coordinate that's only the best in an
approximation sense they still get
something that's reasonable so in other
words would you still get this DK the
sub linear rate that does not depend on
p an answer is yes ok so it scales up by
a constant and i won't get into the
constant so if your approximate nearest
neighbor has some multiplicative
approximation factor ok so then your sub
linear rate just get scaled by an
appropriate function of this
approximation factor
so the key opps up short of all of this
is that your convergence rate is still
asymptotically as a function of P and s
and T it's going to still go to scale as
a squared by T the right so that's where
it comes into place so this is the
number of this is how your objective
decays as a function of T with T is a
number of steps but then each of my
greedy steps is not 0 of 1 it's
typically something let's call that C of
T okay and so the overall computational
complexity is this entire guy so the
complexity of my approximate nearest
neighbor procedure would depend on the
number of samples it would depend on the
number of variables and it would depend
on my approximation factor the greater
lever you give me for the approximation
faster the faster algorithm would be and
here you i want you to think of epsilon
and as some integer I don't want you to
think of it as some 0.001 I want you to
think of it as 2 and 3 and so on okay so
you do reduce the convergence rate by a
factor of 2 but at least it does not
depend on p and so that's what we have
and of course you have a pre-processing
time if you're if the features are not
already available in the data structures
that the approximate nearest neighbor
wants okay so if i'm going to give you a
matrix you'll have to convert it into a
quadtree or you might have to convert it
into appropriate quantized random
projections and so on and so that's
something that you love to worry about
but if you think about it in many
real-world settings i'll give you the
wise i'll give you the exes but i won't
give you which model do use even if i'm
inserting classification the l depends
on the side i get lost and I won't tell
you a bit surrogate loss to use so you
might keep varying the else but your
exes would still be the same and so the
pre-processing time which is to take all
the X's and put them in an appropriate
data structure conducive to approximate
nearest neighbor would be amortized
across all the different applications
and
what's more other interesting thing is
that all the data structures that
approximate nearest neighbor algorithm
views are based on random projections or
at least most of the ones and if you
think about complex sensing the X is
internal random so for instance I might
use random Gaussian roads item axis and
then I am going to use a random
projection to store them in an
appropriate data structure so the
question is instead of generating a P
dimensional Gaussian and then projecting
it down into K again with the random
projection can I actually use
probability theory to actually bring it
down and just directly instantiate the
data structures and that's an open
question which we have not looked into
but that's I think something interesting
but thinking about and so that's anyway
what we have so just to give you some
numbers three minutes okay so i guess
i'll spend just a without getting into
experiments which I think that's
slightly disappointing let me just go or
some just to put some numbers in the
hall what's the complexity of these
nearest neighbor algorithms for those of
you who might not have seen them I'm
sure most of you have so locality
sensitive hashing is the most popular
approximate nearest neighbor data
structure and what it is is just taking
random projections and quantizing them
okay but it's a more general framework
where you want to think about hashing
the data points such that there would be
a coalition if these guys are going to
be close to each other and the property
of a coalition is too small if they are
far apart that's the high level property
that they have to satisfy and their
computational complexity is quasi
quasi-linear in NP okay actually it's
sub linear specifically but i guess i
shouldn't say quasi-linear in this case
I wanted to be less than P and so here
how it scales the speed of the rho where
rho is less than 1 okay and specifically
the row is 1 divided by 1 plus epsilon n
n which is the approximation factor and
again I want you to think of these
approximation factors it's just some
general integer
which reflects our comfort level with
the slowness of your conversion rates so
this could be as large as five or
something and P to the one fifth you
know is as good as a constant in most
cases and of course the caveat is that
if you give me a matrix the
pre-processing time takes time here i
should say quasi-linear it takes time p
to the 1 plus row and so this is
something you could amortize or if you
already have access to that data
structure this is the time and so this
is what we have and then I can actually
speed it up slightly where for instance
I Matthews some randomized FFTs before
the random projections and then I can
actually bring it down to log of P time
taken to do the approximate nearest
neighbor but I can actually bring it
down to the log of P and here is
something interesting in the one minute
that I have you can actually use a very
simple data structure which is a
quadtree quadtree is one of the most
elementary data structures which is a
spatial partitioning yeah both of them
seem to be eps right there are constants
that depend on n actually you're right
so this each of the 125th Epsilon's
that's right the epsilon square knot
that's right so I think in the case
where epsilon is larger than 1 the scale
is epsilon squared so I have to actually
have to actually look at it I'm not
hundred percent sure if it's Kayla's
epsilon square but you're right so in
the case where epsilon is greater than 1
this would be something slightly
different this would this would be super
linear and p and you're right so the
typical setting that approximate nearest
neighbor data structures and analysis or
done is in a setting where epsilon n n
is very close to zero and that's not the
setting vrn here is something that I
just wanted to quickly touch born in the
case where if I'm using very simple data
structure which is quad trees and I do
not encourage you to use this data
structure right because it's very simple
and you should ideally do something
better to just look at the sensitive
hashing the important thing is that if I
assume a mutual incoherence condition on
my on my measurement vectors in other
words the feature vector columns so long
as the dot part is not too large then I
can show that the quadtree actually
works in the sense that the time it
takes is actually sub linear so again I
guess there's some typos here which I'll
after work out exactly what it is but it
is sub linear in p but the constants
here are actually quite bad ok so the
disappointing thing are the experiments
where we are able to be greedy
wonderfully so let me just in the minus
1 seconds a half let me just show you
these experiments so this I think is
just logistic regression and I'm just
comparing cyclic coordinate descent
which is just doing this dumb Swede
through all the coordinates a vanilla
greedy which at each step picks the
coordinate by looking at all the
coordinates of the gradient and picking
the best coordinate and our algorithm
where we use a locality sensitive
hashing data structure to do approximate
nearest neighbor
this is that we do do better than cleary
definitely greedy is extremely slow but
we beat cyclic coordinate isn't only by
a little bit but and again the axes here
are kind of scaled badly because of the
badness of greedy vanilla greedy but
this is still appreciable and what this
says is that even using cyclic
coordinate is and you could be
essentially far away from the optimum
for an almost infinite amount of time
and using this actually better algorithm
gets you a much better optimum but still
it's not as good as we expected and
that's because we didn't really tweak
the lsh data structures and that I think
is a very interesting open problem it
used to um the storage is quasi-linear
in P so I'll just summarize so what I
have given you modulo some
pre-processing or perhaps it's already
available to you in the appropriate data
structures an optimization method the
has computational complexity that's sub
linear in P so this was very surprising
when we brought this up initially but
you can show very easily that this does
give you this nice sub linear dependence
and what we did was just a very simple
connection to approximate nearest
neighbors and I think this opens up a
lot of very interesting open problems
and constructing data structures for
approximate nearest neighbors to the
service of optimization and again the
setting here is different from the
conventional NN setting where they want
multiplicative factors that are very
close to one but it's here we are fine
with larger multiplicative factors and
one other thing that I wanted to mention
is that you can also think of this as a
way to extend sketching to high
dimensional problems normally when we
think of sketching so let's say I want
to solve a linear system y is equal to x
times theta we look at the setting for
instance david wood which talked about
the first day the number of rows are
more than the number of columns and so
then i can talk about sampling for
instance the set of rows appropriately
but
for have a wide matrix where p is very
large you don't want to even think about
subsampling especially if only a few of
these columns are relevant the data is
sparse right if you subsoil you're
already doing the wrong thing right so
the question is how do I sketch and it's
not obvious and what this brings about
is that you can use sketching to solve
the subroutine and that's fine